[Music]
113 questions about evolution with John
Perry hanging out with cousin Paige
Malibu edition why did wills come back
to the ocean
now some people I found don't know this
but whales evolved from land animals so
we have if you go way back in the fossil
record you start to see fish coming out
onto land so you start to see the
evolution of amphibians all vertebrates
all land vertebrates you know tetrapods
things with four appendages in a
backbone they all evolved from these
ancient fish one group became amphibious
another group split off for them became
what we call amniotes the early amniotes
gave rise to reptiles and mammals then
one tiny branch of the mammal
evolutionary tree said go back into the
ocean and that branch was a whale's well
okay sorry
hold on now there's actually several or
in fact many land animal groups that
independently returned to the water
whales are only one of those groups but
they're one of the main ones that we
think of today but there's also you know
there's pleasee a-- sores and mosasaurs
and sea turtles and aquatic snakes and
pinnipeds pinnipeds are you know seals
and sea lions and walruses then there's
manatees all of these groups
independently returned back to the ocean
as well and then to a lesser extent I
suppose you've also got things like
otters and crocodiles and beavers and
marine iguanas and hippos and you know
there's there's a number of them all of
these different groups of animals they
they've either completely given up on or
partially given up on all of the really
complicated land traits that they spent
millions of years evolving you know
millions of years working on and that's
weird right it's like all that work all
of that progression what we would think
of as progression to become a land
animal and then they just throw it all
away and go back into the ocean one of
the reasons that's so weird for us to
think about is that we like to think of
things and it's progressing I like to
think think of things that are more like
us as being more evolved that's actually
the wrong way to think because whatever
advantages happen to be there in an
environment at a particular time
evolution just yeah it doesn't have any
sort of goal any sort of direction
whales were not exactly sure what
enticed them back into the ocean but the
evolution of whales seems to have
happened a few million years after the
extension of the dinosaurs and during
the time of the dinosaurs there were
also lots of other weird predators
they're like reptilian large reptilian
predators in the ocean they all died out
with the dinosaurs as well it's possible
it was just that just the fact that
there was this open niche or niche
depending how you want to say that it
was space there and so whales filled it
the earliest whales that we have in the
fossil record we can tell from isotopes
which is isotopes and their teeth we can
tell that they were most likely
freshwater so the early whales probably
lived somewhat like otters do today and
they were freshwater they were eating
plants they're eating fish and
eventually they were enticed to a full
aquatic lifestyle so just slowly but
surely they give up their you know land
traits and we just still see that they
have lungs and they have the remnants of
hind legs and then in the fossil record
we've coarse trace trace them back to
these land animals so evolution is a
meandering process kind of like my
response was next question
you